i
[Música]
ah
el líbano con no más de 6 millones de
habitantes llegó a acoger a un millón y
medio de refugiados sirios en 2015
convirtiéndose en el país con más
refugiados per cápita a diferencia de
otros países de la región las
autoridades libanesas no han permitido
que se levanten campamentos para los
sirios para que no suceda lo mismo que
con los palestinos que se han convertido
en residentes permanentes es por eso que
los refugiados sirios viven donde pueden
en asentamientos temporales como este en
casas a medio construir o en edificios
abandonados para frenar el flujo de
refugiados las autoridades libanesas
impusieron restricciones lo que ha
llevado muchos sirios a vivir en la
clandestinidad expuestos a la
explotación laboral al trabajo infantil
oa la mendicidad desgraciadamente la
situación de los refugiados ha ido
empeorando en los últimos años debido a
la fuerte crisis económica que afecta a
todos por igual pero golpea con más
fuerza a los sirios
[Música]
desde justamente hoy hace 10 años 56
millones de sirios abandonaron su país
por culpa de la guerra y de los cuales
más de 3,6 millones muchísimos más de la
mitad de estos que se fueron residen
ahora mismo en turquía muchos de ellos
cerca de un millón se estima viven en
estambul en barrios como este denominado
tarlabasi donde la presencia de sirios
es muy grande pero la gran mayoría de
los sirios que viven en turquía viven en
el sur del país muy cerca de la frontera
de lo que antes fue su anterior país
siria cuando en un primer momento cuando
llegaron turquía les recibió con los
brazos abiertos fueron los primeros años
de recepción de sirios en turquía pero
desde 2016 con la crisis económica el
tour que a los turcos han empezado a
verlos
con mucho más recelo y de una forma
mucho más negativa ahora mismo la
población turca quiere una amplia
mayoría que los sirios vuelvan a su país
[Música]
desde que comenzó la guerra en siria
hace 10 años 56 millones de personas han
salido de ese país a las naciones
vecinas pero muchos han venidos de
europa y francia es el segundo país
europeo que más refugiados sirios ha
recibido en estos últimos 10 años se
calcula que son 10.000 para el periodo
2020 2021 francés ha comprometido a
a 10.000 refugiados de todas las
nacionalidades pero siempre las demandas
son mayoritariamente de personas de
origen sirio lo cierto es que debido a
la pandemia las demandas de asilo y
refugio han caído en un 41% y que
francia no es un país prioritario para
los refugiados primero porque es un país
muy burocrático que tarda mucho en
responder a las demandas de asilo en
segundo lugar porque las personas no
pueden trabajar mientras están esperando
una respuesta de las autoridades y
tercero porque es muy complicado
conseguir trabajo según un intelectual
sirio refugiado en alemania y asina las
sales además a los refugiados sirios en
los consulados franceses se les pregunta
su religión y según él las personas que
pertenecen a una minoría religiosa
tienen más chance de ser aceptados en
francia